funerals begin in texas today for the 19
children and two teachers killed in
uvalde amarie joe garza and maite
rodriguez both just 10 years old will be
laid to rest today lily luciano has the
story of one of the teachers killed
whose sister spoke to cbs news lilia
good morning
good morning to you nate we heard from
eva mireles the sister of fourth grade
teacher eva mirelez rather her sister's
name is maggie she told us that eva
loved adventure that she was a hiker
that she was afraid of nothing and that
she would have never imagined losing her
life to her vocation of teaching
i wake up every morning and the first
thing i do is cry because i know that
it's real for the family of eva mireles
the nightmare continues her sister
maggie now facing the most overwhelming
of tasks picking out the last dress
she'll ever wear that was the hardest
thing that i've ever had to do in my
life family members briefed by police
say eva and her co-teacher irma garcia
both died shielding their children from
a gunman who stormed into the classroom
and opened fire killing 19 of their
students i'm sure they didn't even think
about what they were doing twice they
just did it the dog lover mother and
wife to a police officer was finishing
her 17th year of teaching she loved
doing crossfit hiking and bonding with
her loved ones in nature this weekend
was the absolute best weekend ever this
is the last photo maggie has with her
sister from a family trip earlier this
month as the shooting unfolded a family
member texted ava in a group chat asking
if she was okay there was no response i
just knew that my sister was gonna be
okay i never in my dreams thought that
that my sister was not gonna make it i
never thought that maggie is now
fighting for gun control she told us she
met texas governor greg abbott and urged
him to tighten regulations
there's no reason why this type of
weapon
should be among us
governor abbott said that he would be
working on laws to change these things
and i expect to see that but in the
meantime ava's family is trying to
figure out how to navigate life without
her i want everybody to remember her
remember her name remember her face and
remember that she was a hero
she will be remembered like all of these
19 children and that other teacher ms
mirales was 44 years old her body will
be laid to rest on friday and as more
funerals happen throughout the week the
department of justice announced they
have launched a critical review of the
police response to figure out why it
took law enforcement 75 minutes before
they went into that classroom and
stopped the shooter gail
boy that is a question her sister had a
beautiful smile you got me lilia with
the line that she had to pick out the
last dress that she'll ever wear
i know that's true but i never thought
about it quite that way thank you thank
you so much